Bismillah.
[Silence]
reciting the book of Allah and
studying its meanings amongst
each other except that the the
tranquility of Allah will
descend upon them and the mercy
of Allah will envelop them and
the angels will surround them
and Allah will mention them
with those who are close us to
he. The word, the book of Allah
is one of those words in the
Quran and Sunnah that if they
are mentioned together, they
have two separate meanings and
if they're mentioned
separately, they have, they
have, the same meaning, okay?
So, ali Imam Abdul Qayyim
Rahima Allah mentions in his
his book, Al Al yeah. He
mention that in the language of
the companions and in the
language of the the prophet
when the book of Allah is
mentioned it includes the of
the prophet in the book of
Allah is mentioned and includes
the so when he discusses the
book of Allah, he's speaking
about the revelation of Allah
because the is part of the book
not part of the Quran but part
of the broader meaning of the
book of Allah. Meaning, the
book of law of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. So, when Allah
mentions in the Quran that he
gave Musa the book, he gave
Dawood the book. He gave the
prophets the book, right? Every
messenger he gave the book.
What is meant by the book?
Meaning, the revelation of
Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala and
that revelation has three
branches of knowledge. Quran,
the Sunnah, all the revelations
of Allah to the to the prophets
and messengers consist of three
branches of knowledge. What are
those branches of knowledge?
Number one, the description of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. The
first branch is the knowledge
of Allah. The second branch is
the knowledge of Allah's will.
Meaning his laws. Right? The
third branch is the
the ruling of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. So, the first branch
is is anything having to do
with Allah's names or
attributes or descriptions or
actions or that's one branch of
knowledge. The next branch of
knowledge are the laws of
Allah. Do this, do not do this,
etcetera. The third branch of
knowledge is the judgment of
Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is good This is bad. This
is this is good. This is evil.
This is right. This is wrong.
This is filthy. This is clean.
Right? This is the judgment of
Allah. If you do this, you are
prone to these consequences.
Allah will judge the one who
does this by punishing him this
way. Allah will judge the one
who does this by rewarding him
this way, etcetera, etcetera.
These are the three branches of
knowledge that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala sent down to humanity
Alhamdulillah, everything
relevant to us to the end of
time. from all of the
revelations of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to all of mankind
have been included in the Quran
and Sunnah. Everything.
Everything relevant to us.
There may be little details
that are not relevant to us
that are not mentioned in the
Quran and Sunnah. But
everything relevant to us. The
gist. Of what Allah sent to
mankind as guidance. in the
form of revelation is all found
in the Quran and in the of the
prophet so the point here that
we're making is that the book
of Allah is more broad in
meaning when it's mentioned
alone than merely the Quran.
When when the companions or the
prophet says the book of Allah,
he's referring to the Quran and
the and the of the prophet
However, if he mention them
together. He says the Quran and
the now we have separate.
They're separate. Right? So
this is an important thing to
know and a very good fact about
learning the Quran and the
Sunnah. Another example is Al
Fakir and Al Muskin for
instance. Iman and Islam. These
are also words that carry these
same meanings. If Islam is
mentioned alone, it includes a
man. If a man is alone, it
includes Islam, right? If
they're mentioned alone, if
they're mentioned together,
Islam refers to outward actions
and Iman refers to actions of
belief and actions of the
heart, right? Another example
of this is righteousness and
god fearing. Right, when
they're mentioned together,
Albir is doing good deeds and a
taqwa is refraining from evil
deeds but when taqwa is
mentioned alone, it includes
doing good deeds and when is
mentioned alone. It is
including refraining from evil
deeds. This is an important
list. There's a long list
actually that some of the
scholars have tried to point
out throughout their Tefacia
throughout their works of this
type of word where it's two
words or three words, sometimes
four words, right? So, for
example, the word Edine, the
religion, it carries the
meaning of and Iman and Islam.
right? It carries all four of
those meanings and all of those
words carry those meanings as
well when they're mentioned
alone but when they're all
mentioned together, they have
different meanings which will
be what we'll discuss tonight
after Isha inshallah. We are
continuing in the 10 points
that Ibn al Kaya mentions with
regards to the issues and the
things that a person can do or
that Allah does to open the
person's heart. We mentioned
the heart has a has a surface
to it and in order for that
surface to be penetrated and in
order for a seed of a man and
faith to be planted firmly in
it, it has to be dug up. Just
when you plant a seed in
the ground, right? You have to
disturb the earth. You can't
leave it it is. You have
to dig it up and that's a
violent action, right? It's
unpleasant and the same thing
with learning When you are
learning and you have an open
mind, your what you think you
know is constantly being tested
and constantly being reformed.
Because as some of our scholars
have told us
knowledge does not accept that
a person be that a person be
rigid. It does not accept
rigidity. Meaning that a person
no I believe what I believe and
that's it. Nothing else can
change it. That can't be the
way that your mind works. There
are certain things that yes. I
believe Allah and his messenger
and the books and the angels
and so on and so forth but
there are also details that for
40 years, 50 years you may
maybe a Muslim and always knew
it to be this way and then you
come to the class and your mind
is blown because you find out
that this was actually
incorrect or that it was
actually something that you had
misunderstood. That's the
process of knowledge and the
students of knowledge,
scholars, Shiyuk, people that
spend their life in they are
constantly digging and
planting. Digging and planting
and that process is continuous.
So, if you are not willing to
dig, if you are not willing to
allow your mind to be open and
your heart to be opened, then,
you will never, you will never
learn. This is the process of
learning. Learning comes with,
comes with that, action of
friction, of discomfort, of
violence that happens where you
have to open your heart and
open your mind a little bit.
Now, we're not talking about
opening your mind to everyone
and anyone. We're talking about
opening your mind and opening
your heart by saying this is
something I may not know. This
is something that I may be
ignorant of. This is something
I may have misunderstood. This
is something, I know this
narration for all these years.
But now, I've understood it a
different way. I've actually
misunderstood it for many
years, right? It etcetera.
There there are examples of
this. so, this is why we
come to class. This is why we
come to lectures. This is why
we go to people who study and
spend their time and their
lives studying. We come to
learn from them. Because this
is what they specialize in. And
we come to take from their
knowledge. They work hard
behind the scenes. So, for
example, for me to give a class
this, this is a
combination of of of 15 years
of studying. So, so I am
boiling it down and giving it
to you and dispensing it to
you. Not everybody has that
time or has that dedication or
has that knack to go and a
scholar. That's why we have
scholars and that's why we have
to respect them. We have to
revere them and we have to
protect them and we have to
defend them. right? Because
they are the our sources of
knowledge. They are our
connection between us and the
prophet and our connection
between us and Allah. Knowledge
wise, not in in in worship. Not
in worship. Scholars don't have
any special powers to forgive
you. They don't even know if
they're Going to be forgiven,
right? We do not hollify
scholars rather we revere them
and we respect them because of
the effort that they have given
and because of the specialties
that they have and the gifts
that they've have. So, of these
things, mentions and we're here
on the last two. Says,
if
how
[Silence]
important and paramount things
that opens a person's heart to
the Quran and Sunnah.
Is that a person not only open
his heart but that he clean his
heart out of the things which
are rejected and frowned upon
and
denounced by Allah and his
messenger
What a what is this mean? our
ears and our eyes. They are
direct paths to our heart,
right? And whatever we subject
our our our focus with our eyes
with two, this goes directly
into your heart. You've opened
your heart and it's going
directly in there. Whether it
is you agree with it or
disagree with it, it's still
going into your heart, okay?
The same thing with listening.
There's a difference between
hearing something and
listening. When you Listen to
something. Meaning that you are
giving it your attention. You
have now opened a direct path
through your hearing to your
heart. Now, society around us,
the time and place and and and
and, and the, and the time and
history that we live, what is
the majority of things that go
into our heart from the outside
world. If we're honest, they're
not good right? They're bad
things. You you know, the
majority of society is on a
verge of pushing towards evil,
pushing towards decadence. If a
person can't see this, then,
they can't see, right? Things
that are, things that are
considered to be very grave in
the book of Allah are
considered to be not a big deal
in the in the society and in
the time that live in. I'm not
just pointing out and saying
only in America. Yes, America
is a beacon of this in a way.
However, the rest of the world
is followed in suit, right? And
Islam started strange and it
will return to being strange as
it began. The prophet said, So,
all day, when you are listening
to things and when you are
looking at things, even if they
are Simple things, right? Let's
take an example. Everything
that you see is a lesson.
Everything that you see. It's a
consequence. It's a lesson.
What does that mean? Let's say
you look at a little silly
video, right? Some little
TikTok video or YouTube or
whatever is going on today and
and you see some little funny
video, right? Some kind of
prank or some kind of you are
subjecting yourself to
something that either in
accordance with the Quran and
Sunnah or against the Quran and
Sunnah. Whether you agree with
it or not, you are you are
willingly subjecting yourself
to it. So, you're not rejecting
it and these things are getting
worse and worse. and that's
what the prophet said would
happen near the end of time. He
said in the narration of
Abdullah bin al Az which is in
Sahih Muslim in the book of
Imara. He said
[Silence]
Allah
each one of these will dwarf
the that preceded it. What does
that mean? It means that what
came before will seem to be
minimal compared to what is now
and what comes tomorrow of evil
will make today's evil seem
minimal. It will dwarf it.
Right? We can give examples of
this. A good example of this is
sexual perversion that is
taking place in society today.
Just even in this country. A
non-Muslim country. a
Christian country, non-Muslim
country, 50 60 years ago 70
years ago a woman would never
be seen pregnant from from
unwed and have a bastard child.
This was something that was
outrageous and many documents
and documentation, many cases
have been documented of women
going to secret abortion
clinics in order to abort
these, these children, and
these fetuses because of the
shame that would incur them for
having premarital, premarital
relationships outside of,
outside of marriage. Now,
that's nothing. Why is that
nothing? Because we had first,
women would dress a certain way
and then we had dating and then
we had bastard children. We
tried to hide that and then we
added another layer of
perversion and then we had
singers and movies and all
these things that came along
and glorified and romanticized
to us these things. Until we
another wave such as
homosexuality and then another
wave that will come such as
such as other types of sexual
perversion which I'd rather not
mention, right? And these
things continue to come in
waves and waves to where now we
look at a man and a woman, a
man has a girlfriend. They've
been living together for 10
years. They have four kids.
They have five kids. They're a
lovely couple. We don't even
look at it as being anything
anymore. Why is that because
that is the nature of the fit
end, the waves of that will
come upon this as the prophet
mentioned. And so, a lot of
what we see, a lot of what we
hear are bad things. They're,
they're, they're, they are not
in align with the Quran and
Sunnah. Whether it be how
people speak, how people walk,
how people conduct themselves.
, pranks that play on each
other are totally
inappropriate, right? Lies that
they tell certain things. It's
supposed to be funny, right?
But what you, when you're
subjecting yourself to it, you
are desensitizing your heart to
this thing that is evil. It is
evil. Even if all of society
says, not a big deal. What's
the big problem? Right? when I
was growing up back back in in
in in Palestine, even here in
America, in my in my mother's
time, right? In the 50s, in the
60s, when Elvis Presley was a
big thing, he could only get on
TV and only this portion of his
body here from the stomach up
could be shown because what his
legs were doing in his hips
were considered to be
inappropriate. We cannot show
that on television. Right
Compare that to where we are
today. right? Now, we say,
Elvis, please come back
compared to what we see today,
right? This is the nature of
fitna. So, we have become
desensitized. You'll read
things of the Quran, you'll
read things of the sunnah and
they seem minutia and they
seem little things but in
reality, they are major things
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and the knot is becoming untied
and loosened in our hearts So,
we have a lot of things that
are in our hearts, all of us,
that are in direct conflict
with the Quran and Sunnah, in
direct conflict with what good
is by the yardstick and the
measurement of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. And so, in order for
good to come into our hearts,
we have to get rid of the evil
that is in it. How do we get
rid of that evil? That's the
question now. he says
these things that are in the
heart. These things that have
found their way into our heart
and settled in our heart. A
direct consequence of these
things, of this evil, of this
filth that is in our hearts, a
direct consequences that the
heart will become, tight, and
restricted, and only partially
open. Another consequences that
the heart will be in constant
torment. It will be torn
between good and evil all of
the time because you are
exposing yourself to good and
you're exposing yourself to
evil and constantly the heart
is being, is being, is is going
through a type of punishment,
all of the time. So, we
distract ourselves from this
but when we sit down by
ourselves and and be quiet and
don't listen to anything and
don't watch anything, that
feeling of discomfort starts to
manifest itself. uncomfortable.
Let me grab my phone. Let me
look at something. Let me watch
a funny video. Let me go watch
a movie. Let me let me listen
to something. Why? Because that
is part of the punishment of
the heart that goes on in the
heart. That literally causes
torment and pain in the heart
because good and evil are
battling inside of inside of
this heart which is not yet
pure enough. He says, and these
Things that are evil that we
find in our hearts, they may
stand as a hindrance and a
barrier between the sick heart
becoming well. It may stop the
medicine. So, we will read the
Quran, We will read the we'll
act upon some of the things but
if we expose ourselves to evil
more so than we do to good,
what will happen, what will
happen is, is that we will
start to we will start to block
the medicine which is the Quran
and Sunnah because of the
amount of illness that we have
pumped into our hearts and
dumped into our hearts. it,
you know, evil is it's
it's a bacteria. If
you, if you, if you continue to
expose yourself to the to to
the bacteria and it grows and
multiplies and and flourishes,
right? And then you try to
enter use antibiotics It might
it might work. It might not
work, right? The it's nothing
wrong with the antibiotics.
It's just that the that the
body is not accepting it. The
bacteria is too powerful. So,
we have to up the the the
antibiotics and we have to keep
making them stronger and
stronger because the evil is
mutating. And so these things
will be a hindrance for the
heart to become pure and the
heart to become healed. this is
important for us to heal our
hearts, Heal our hearts from
what? Heal our hearts from the
evil that has has found its
place in them. Whether we
notice this evil or not.
Whether we recognize it as evil
or not. And that's that's one
of the worst case scenarios. Is
that a person have evil in his
heart and not even recognize
that this is evil. That a
person be ill and not even know
that he's ill or sick. This is
the biggest problem because
identifying the illness is half
of the cure. As the scholars of
Islam have mentioned.
He says that if a person does
all of the things that we have
just discussed of the things
that open the heart. But the
does not work to rid his heart
of the filth and evil that is
in it and does not clean his
heart and cleanse it and purge
it, then, he will not end up
with a very open heart at all.
And all of these work to
beautify and embed better his
heart may be in vain. Ibn Al
Kaim says, he says
And then a person will find
himself in a situation where
there are two things which are
fighting for his heart. He has
the evil that he has allowed
into his heart and then he has
the good that he has put into
his heart. And so now they are
fighting constantly. And this
is what psychologists call
cognitive dissonance. He says
and eventually one of them will
win. By the time of his death,
one of them will eventually win
and overcome the other. Either
completely or partially. and he
will belong to whichever of
those two wins that battle. He
those two wins that battle. So,
the heart has these, has these
two things in them. How do we
purge the heart? This is the
question. Number one, the first
important thing to do is to
stop whatever it is that is
injected, injecting, excuse me,
injecting evil into your heart.
That's the first thing. Stop
the flow of sewage that is
going into your heart. and when
you do that, the heart has
become addicted to it It's
because you repent from doing
something doesn't mean that you
won't suffer withdrawal from
it. You will because the heart
is become dependent and and and
has come to enjoy and fancy
this evil thing. So, you're
going to go through a period of
withdrawal. Just you do
from a drug. Same thing. and if
you'd to test this, erase
Facebook off of your phone. Try
it. That time that you take,
that half hour, every three,
four hours where you scroll
through Facebook, erase
Facebook, and to spend those
times reading the Quran and
Sunnah. Not from a phone. Open
a book and read from the book
and see what happens. You'll
start to go through withdrawal.
Literal withdrawal. You'll have
depression you'll have anxiety,
you'll have this, you'll have
that because the illness is
fighting back You're going
through withdrawal. That's
what's happening right? Try to
turn off this program and open
the Quran. Try to turn off this
song or this music and turn on
the recitation of the Quran or
a lecture of a scholar or
something of the sort. What
will happen? In the first few
weeks, you will find yourself
in the state of anxiety. but
when that subsides and the more
you continue to put in good
into your heart and you've
stopped the influx of evil into
your heart. what will happen
over a month or two or three or
five? You will start to look
back at what you did and say,
my god, what was I doing? And
you will start to see the
things that you looked at and
enjoyed and laughed at all the
time and took for granted as
being things that are unholy
and unworthy. Things that are
uninappropriate. Am I making
sense here with what with what
I'm saying? This is the process
of, this is the process of
rejecting evil. Right? It's
the same thing. If if a
person goes on a diet, so let's
say. This is the, the, the, the
spirit and the, the body are
very similar in these ways.
Let's say you go on a diet. You
say, you know what, I'm
going to cut out sugar
completely. You're going to go
through real physical
withdrawal from sugar. Right?
and you're going to spend a
month, maybe two, where you're
actually craving sugar and you
wish you could have it and this
and that but after that
subsides, when you actually go
back and have something sweet,
you won't even enjoy it. So,
this is some kind of sugar
cone. It's too, it's too sweet.
Right? And the same thing
happens with the heart. So, how
do we purge the heart? Number
one, we stop the flow of sewage
into the heart. We stop it.
don't do it anymore. Whatever
it is, I I don't know what it
is. For different people, it's
different things but I will say
and many people will will
disagree and come up with all
kinds of things that they
rebuttal with. When I say
things Facebook is not a
good place to be. It's not.
Instagram is a terrible place
to be, okay? TikTok is the
worst place you could be on the
internet. One of the worst
places, right?
but then,
a person will say,
well, Sheikh, your lecture is
being streamed on Facebook
right? Your lectures being
streamed on Facebook. How are
you denouncing Facebook when it
is actually something that you
utilize? This is this is
something that we've kind of
been forced to do because if we
leave a platform completely
open to evil, it would be
completely overtaken by evil.
And so, the scholars of Isla
have chosen to enter a platform
in order to try to minimize the
damage and the evil that
flourishes therein. It's a
different thing. If you have
it, let's say you have Facebook
and you just you know, you use
it just to watch this lecture
or this lecture or this
lecture. That's fine, right?
Use it very sparingly but to
turn it on and just scroll
through it, scroll through it.
Oh, just 10 minutes. It just
takes five minutes before you
know five hours is going by
throughout your whole day. Five
hours In five hours, you could
have learned archaic Arabic.
You could have memorized entire
chapters of the Quran. You
could have spent that time with
your children. Right? And so,
because of this social media
issue that we have, TikTok and
all of these things. It's just
a thirty2nd video. Yeah, it's a
thirty-second video of nothing
but pure garbage or if it's not
harmful, the best case
scenario, it's not beneficial.
So, it's just 32nd video but
when you add it up and you
watch 300 videos, how many
seconds do we have now? How
many hours have gone by now?
we've all been there, right?
We've all been there where
you're surfing on YouTube and
you find yourself three hours
later in some strange, obscure
part of YouTube and some rabbit
hole watching something you
have no business watching and
the prophet would make dua and
part of his dua
Right? He used to make dua. Oh
Allah, I seek refuge in you
from knowledge that is not
beneficial. There is knowledge
that is not beneficial. I seek
refuge in you from knowledge
that is not beneficial and an
eye that does not tear up with
your remembrance and a heart
that is not focused and
concentrated on your
remembrance and your worship
And devout. And I seek refuge
you from a stomach that cannot
be filled, right? This is the
kind of dua the prophet would
make. So, in closing, it is
time for then now. Just to kind
of review what we've spoken
about today and that is, you
know, a lot of people will
rebuttal and say, oh, you know,
social media were able to do
things and so on. So, that's
fine. What I'm saying is, these
things, yes, they are a
double-edged sword but one edge
is sharper than the other and
the major of it is not good. We
can admit that. It's not good.
And every time your finger goes
to erase the Facebook app or
the TikTok app, you get a
little voice in your head that
says, oh but wait, Sheikh so
and so is on this app. Oh,
wait. I use it for this. Ignore
that voice and erase it. And
selectively choose and vet
exactly what you're going to
allow your ears to hear and
what you're going to allow your
eyes to see. If you do that
your heart will become purged
eventually but it won't become
purged only by doing that. You
have to as well continue to
enter and flood it with the
light of Allah, the Quran, and
the Sunnah and the good things
that are good and be around
good people and listen to good
things.